so there were some kind of proposals he
said no he never spoke to any of them
okay okay I think I understand
I Now understand that this actually
hasn't been like a formal process it's
just sort of talk looking back on the
restaurant now I feel bad that I didn't
give Rishi the benefit of the doubt it
was definitely a misunderstanding
I have a question does she have any
questions about why we're asking so many
questions
[Music]
she's saying that yeah she is thinking
which is like her guess is that he must
like a girl
foreign
so
you can let her know that I have
something to say uh to everyone in the
room okay uh
okay you can go ahead Randy Okay so
I am here to support Jen as she tries to
figure out
her relationship with Rishi
and
they're pending engagement announcement
I'm in a very heavy shocking moment if
the translation wasn't there I would be
the person translating and I would
change the topic instantly
but I don't know how to stop this
conversation
uh
Jen or rishika
foreign
[Music]